bonsoir je m'appelle clément ma vie je
suis chercheur en sciences sociales à
l'utc de compiègne l'utc c'est une école
d'ingénieurs et moi je suis spécialiste
des relations entre numérique et
démocratie est ce que je voudrais
discuter avec vous ce que je voudrais
présenter ce soir c'est finalement
revenir sur l'ambiguïté de notre rapport
aux technologies numériques et pour ça
j'ai essayé de partir d'un paradoxe d'un
côté on est contents d'utiliser plus en
plus de services qui s'imbriquent dans
nos vies on est content par exemple de
rentrer en beurre et en même temps on
voit bien que ces services qui pose des
problèmes
demandez donc aux chauffeurs de taxi ce
qu'ils pensent des humeurs et malgré
cela malgré le fait qu'on les voit ces
problèmes on change pas nos pratiques et
même on utilise de plus en plus ses
services pourquoi à mon avis une partie
de la réponse vient du fait qu'on a du
mal à identifier le problème
derrière l'est problème que derrière les
colères sectorielle qu'on peut voir
qu'on peut identifier et bien on a du
mal à remonter à la source et pour moi
en fait
peut-être que tout simplement cette
source
c'est les géants du monde de l'ateq eux
mêmes ce qu'on appelle les gars femmes
vous connaissez les gars femmes c'est
google amazon facebook apple et
microsoft
voilà peut-être que c'est tout
simplement eu le problème
peut-être que tout simplement leur
modèle économique n'est pas compatible
avec notre manière de vivre parce que
dans un une logique où on a ceux ci ont
passé naturellement innovations
technologiques et progrès social
on a beaucoup misé sur eux on s'est dit
que grâce à ces nouvelles technologies
on allait entrer dans une société de
l'information
on allait entrer dans une société de la
connaissance on allait avoir des
nouvelles technologies de communication
qui allait faire tomber les barrières
géographiques on allait pouvoir
communiquer que des gens l'autre au bout
du monde en salle et faire tomber les
barrières temporelle des questions de
décalage horaire et autres on s'est dit
que leur leader même bout d'un moment
tellement ils nous veulent du bien ces
gens là peut-être qu'ils allaient
devenir nos leaders peut-être qu'ils
allaient devenir nos leaders politiques
on a bien vu mark zuckerberg le patron
de facebook qui envisage de se présenter
à la maison blanche pour devenir le
président américain mais ce qu'on se
rend compte
progressivement c'est que la magie elle
opère de moins en moins le charme est en
train d'être rompu
on est dans une période qu'on pourrait
qualifier de désenchantement et début
il ya un article de the economist qu'a
mis les pieds dans le plat il a parlé de
ce qu'il appelle le tec clash
le retour de bâton concernant les gens
de la tech
qu'est ce que ce serait ce retour de
bâton
ces deux choses c'est d'une part dire ya
de plus en plus de critiques qui
finissent par ferney les géants de la
tech et deuxièmement il y en a marre de
les voir toujours s'excuser à chaque
fois qu'on les prend la main dans le pot
de confiture
donc il y aura un retour de bâton ou
finalement les gens sont en train de
comprendre que c'est d'ailleurs ils ne
veulent pas que du bien et c'est vrai on
a plein de raisons de se méfier et
d'être critique on peut prendre
l'exemple des fuites massives de données
vous avez peut-être entendu parler de la
sphère cambridge analytica ou en fait
les données d'utilisateurs facebook ont
été
aspiré revendu haineux revendu notamment
pour influencer le cours de campagne
électorale les campagnes électorales
américaines présidentielles américaines
qui ont mené à l'élection donald trump
la campagne pour le référendum
concernant le prêt qu site
on leur reproche également leur
passivité concernant la propagation de
ce qu'on appelle les fakes news des
fausses nouvelles paraît qu'on doit dire
les infos que maintenant on leur
reproche également leur complaisance par
rapport aux pratiques de surveillance
des états comme l'a dénoncé
edouard snowdon et on voit également
apparaître des controverses comme
lorsque l'état du zimbabwe décide de
vendre les données concernant ses
citoyens pour contribuer à améliorer les
intelligents les intelligences
artificielles chinoise vraiment on voit
qu'en fait d'acteurs peut-être qu'ils ne
veulent pas que du bien mais il ya des
réactions quand même face à ça bon les
états les réactions sont assez timides
il ya des débuts de régulation notamment
de régulation du marché du travail
récemment les travailleurs qui sont
associés à eau plate forme notamment
vous savez ceux qui viennent vous livrer
en vélo les bons petits plats dans des
gros sacs à dos là eh bien ils ont
réussi à faire reconnaître leur statut
de salarié avec les protections et
avantages qui vont avec
on voit bien que c'est est reconnu par
le conseil d'état pour les plateformes
comme des livres ou que les travailleurs
associés sont des salariés et qui
bénéficie donc de protection
les chauffeurs de vtc comme bear se sont
aussi mobilisés pour faire reconnaître
la particularité de leur métier on
commence tout doucement à parler de la
possibilité et c'est très conditionnel
de taxes tu es aussi ces gens pour
essayer de territorialiser un peu les
profits qu'ils font
évitez tout soit rapatrié aux états unis
dans les maisons mères il ya aussi des
formes de réactions politiques
typiquement quand il ya une grosse
scandale quand une grosse controverse
on convoque les dirigeants dans nous
représentants mark zuckerberg a eu un
moment de contrition à ces fameux devant
le congrès américain où il a dû
s'excuser de tous les problèmes causés
par facebook et des des problèmes de
collecte de données
voilà on leur tape sur les doigts
puis on a aussi les citoyens qui se
mobilisent
alors on a des collectifs qui se
mobilisent pour demander plus de justice
fiscale
comment comme je l'évoquais précédemment
et on a aussi en californie des gens qui
se mobilisent notamment parce qu'en fait
la présence des salariés des cg en
attaque dérégule complètement fait qu'on
va exploser le marché de l'immobilier ou
les salaires mirobolants de ses salariés
rendre inaccessible la propriété aux
habitants qui étaient là avant les
géants de matech est peut-être plus
nouveau on a aussi une multiplication
des critiques internes qui viennent de
salariés de ces géants de matech qui
joue en fait un rôle de lanceur d'alert
on a vu par exemple récemment
l'inventeur du bouton like vous savez le
petit pouce levé et bien l'inventeur du
bouton like qui a partagé ses états
d'âme et qui a regretté comment son
invention été utilisés on a récemment
encore un autre cadre de facebook qui a
assuré en public qu'il interdirait à ses
propres enfants d'utiliser le réseau
social
on a encore un autre exemple les
salariés de google ont publié une lettre
ouverte donc dans la presse pour
dénoncer un projet porté par leur
entreprise
ce projet s'appelle dragonfly en quoi
consiste dragonfly l'idée
et de faire une déclinaison du moteur de
recherche très connu google adaptés aux
demandes du gouvernement chinois
notamment en terme de censure de faire
une version censurée de google et les
salariés ont refusé ce projet en mettant
en avant le fait qu'il s'était pas
vraiment engagé chez google pour porter
ce type de projet est allé et défendre
ce type de valeurs dont ils ont rendu
publique ce projet ce qui a contribué à
le faire échouer donc ces réactions
c'est résistance doivent nous inspirer
et nous montre que finalement il n'ya
rien d'inéluctable
on peut avoir de l'impact sur les
trajectoires de l'innovation sur ces
innovations technologiques
il est possible en fait tout simplement
de faire la politique de changer les
rapports de force et de venir modifier
ses trajectoires il est possible de
reprendre le contrôle
et ça passe par plusieurs choses d'abord
pour changer les choses il faut changer
de regard sur les technologies accepter
le fait qu'on puisse porter une critique
sociale de ces technologies
une critique par le bas par ses
utilisateurs que les utilisateurs
puissent exprimer leur point de vue
critique est étonnant en démocratie
qu'ils soient écoutés
en fait il faut accepter que les
technologies sont des structures
sociales qui impacte notre quotidien et
qu'elles ne sont pas neutres les
technologies ne sont pas neutres et par
ce fait elles doivent être discutable
elles ne sont pas autonomes elles sont
conçues dans la société pour la société
et évidemment la société a son mot à
dire concernant les orientations
technologiques dont elle subira les
conséquences et reprendre la main ça
passe aussi
art valoriser des alternatives
encourager les expériences les
expérimentations qui nous montrent qu'un
autre chemin est possible notamment les
expérimentations autour ce qu'on appelle
les communs numérique c'est-à-dire les
projets qui sont portées gouverner
développé par des communautés de
pratique
l'exemple le plus connu que vous
connaissez tous deux comme un numérique
c'est sûrement wikipédia est une
encyclopédie collaborative en ligne où
chaque jour des millions de personnes
viennent contribuer à enrichir la
connaissance partagée en contribuant des
articles où chaque jour des millions de
personnes viennent lire ces articles
le deuxième exemple c'est une base de
données qu'on appelle open food fight
open foot fax répertorie d'informations
concernant l'alimentation
l'idée c'est de pouvoir mieux connaître
notre alimentation et éventuellement les
produits additifs qu'on peut qu'on peut
y mettre le troisième exemple c'est
openstreetmap un outil de cartographie
collaborative qui souhaite se poser
comme une alternative à google maps
dernière points c'est encourager le fait
de valaury de mettre des valeurs de
mettre de l'éthique
dès la conception des technologies il
faut aussi encourager les entrepreneurs
à porter dans le numérique des
entreprises à mission à un an qu
encourager le fait que des entrepreneurs
prennent en main cette question des
valeurs et tente de se frayer un chemin
pour porter un modèle économique autour
de ses valeurs alternatives aux gars
femmes bref on se rend compte d'une
manière générale et c'est surtout ce que
je voulais vous dire que il n'y a pas de
raison que l'agenda économique des
géants de la tech
guide celui de la société et il n'y a
pas de raison que le confort des usages
empêche notre esprit critique de
fonctionner il ya plus qu'à merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]